GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE. HI IN
RESPONSE TO THE KILL THE
NINETEEN A MERCHANT SEE AN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHER
INCIDENT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWED. AND WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE
FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN AND
AS YOU CAN SEE IT'S ON THE
SCREEN FOR EVERYONE TO SEE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES JIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR STYLE ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A NUMBER- THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE I NEEDED
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO.
ADDRESS THAT COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
pSERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESSING AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARING. IT IS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY BUT BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM I WOULD ASK
OUR CONSULTANT. ACTING
SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MICHAEL AND WE CAN HEAR
YOU SO. RIGHT FROM THE PLEASE
ENTER MICRONS WE CONCLUDE
PLEASE ARE HERE WE'VE HERE
NIELSEN. NEIL FOR HERE
HERTZBERG HERE THIRTY BURKE
HERE LEYVA HERE LATE HERE
NEWMAN YOUR NUMBER HERE WE A
CORE. TECH. WE HAVE A QUORUM
PRESENT WE HAVE ONE AND ON OUR
WE TO WELCOME CENTER I BURKE TO
PER S. B. TWENTY NINTH. AND-
AND WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IN SENATOR. UP FOR SO
MISTER CONGRATULATE ON.
CHAIRMANSHIP THIS ATTACK CAN-
I'VE HAD SOME OF. HERE AND HAS
ALL BEEN. MOST ARE PRODUCTIVE.
BIG SHOES TO FILL SIR AT AND
WHAT ARE YOUR WHAT'S YOUR SHOES.
YEAH. WELL IT IS CASE IS ABOUT
A- SO YEAH YOU'LL BE EASY TO
FILL- SO IT. I HAVE BEEN YOU B.
TWO NINE WHICH REQUIRE K.
ELECTION TO MAIL A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT READ ACT VOTERS AND
REQUIRES COUNTY LET OF TO USE A
ALL FIVE. BALLOT TRACK SYSTEM
FOR ALL CAN IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. DO THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PANDA CAL ENACTED B. EIGHT
SIXTY LAST BY THE MEMBER WE
REQUIRE THE ALREADY ACTIVE
VOTERS A VOTE BY MAIL. BALLOT
FOR THE NOVEMBER THREE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION WE SAW A RECORD
TURNOUT IN THAT ELECTION- THE
TURNOUT WAS EIGHTY POINT 67%
THE HIGHEST SINCE NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO- BOTH THE VOTERS AND
ELECTION WORKERS NEED TO BE
GUARANTEED A SAFE ENVIRONMENT
ORDER TO CONDUCT ELECTIONS.
THIS BILL WILL GUARANTEE THAT
ELIGIBLE VOTERS LIVING IN
JURISDICTIONS CONDUCTING
ELECTIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE MAILED A BALLOT. IN
ORDER TO GIVE THE OPTION FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO VOTE AT
HOME. IF THEY WISH- JUST AS AN
ASIDE THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTIONS- I PERSONALLY THOUGHT
WORKED. VERY VERY WELL- WE HAD
SOME GLITCHES IN ORANGE COUNTY
WE HAD A FAKE POLLING PLACE
WHICH I THINK IS BEING DEALT
WITH IN LEGISLATION THIS YEAR
AND THERE WERE SOME. OF FAKE
BALLOT BOXES THAT WERE
DISTRIBUTED- AROUND CERTAIN
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA- THAT'S
NOT ANY GOOD AND I THINK THAT'S.
BEING ADDRESSED AS WELL. MISTER
CHAIR BOB A BID HAPPENED RISK
ANY- TO TEST. IN MISS ADELE.
ATTACK A LOS. THE ORANGE CAN
PLEASE. ELECTION SLIGHTLY FOR
THE OR COUNTY OF. AND I BELIEVE
MISTER MA MR STATE OFFICES ON
THE- THANK YOU FOR NUMBER GUY
I'M TO MAKE SURE. TO DO ACCEPT
THE MET. DO THANK THERE'S A
GOOD TO GET THE CLEAR. SO DO TO
COULD REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
THE HEARING TECHNO. ISSUE AND
CLEANING- WE ARE STYLE A TIMELY
FOR TESTS. OF EACH TO HAVE
PLAYED THREE MINUTES TO EACH
SHOPPERS TESTIFY TO EACH SIDE
IS THE LA- AND THEN WE GO TO.
THE WHO TO. SUPPORTING OUR
OPPOSING WE THAT THEY DO
PROVIDE THEIR NAME FILL. AND
THEIR POSITION WE GO FOR. SO I
JUST WE HAVE A DE TACO LOLA.
THE ORANGE EMPLOY SO. ON THE
PHONE LINE AT THE. OPERATOR IF
YOU ESTABLISH THAT WITH TO
INVITE HER TO BE OUR- WITH. IN
HIS UNDERSTAND IT- TIFFANY MY
IN THE SEARCH. OF STATE OFFICE
BE ANNOUNCED FOR ANY TECHNICAL-
VISIT TAGS. ARE YOU THERE. HE I
AM HERE WELL AND PLEASE PER
WITH YOUR- THANK YOU THANK YOU
GLAZER AND- AS MY NAME IS
DALKON THE LOWER I AM THE
SECRETARY FOR THE ORANGE CARE
EMPLOYEE BECAUSE- AS WELL AS
ELECTION RIGHT. FOR THE ORANGE
RED BOTH. THE BLACK NOVEMBER
WAS WITH FOR HELPING FORM
COUNTY IMPLEMENT THE STATE
BURKE FOUND AT FOUR THREE BY
EDWARD AND AB SIX BY A MEMBER
BERMAN. I HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
OR COUNTY WITH THE WILL. ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE LAW APPLY TO
THE NOVEMBER. AT AS THAT- BURKE
STATE WE HAD IN THE CORE TWO
WITH ALMOST EIGHTY SEVEN PER IN
ORDER COUNTY IN THE HISTORY.
DID THE MEDICAL BUT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC MY COWORKERS AND I.
REALLY HAVE. THE PER. PUT IN
FOR THE- THAT HAVE TO WORK AT
HOLD ARCADE BOTH CENTERS DURING
THE PERIOD. FOLLOWING THE
ELECTION- SHE HELD A MEETING
SENATOR- BURKE. IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE SPECIAL
ELECTION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BUT NINETEEN IS OBVIOUSLY STILL
STILL WITH US BUT THAT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF BOTH VOTERS. AND ARE
ELECTION WORKERS AT THE POLLS
NEED TO BE PUT AT RISK WHEN WE
HAVE AN ELECTION. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY AND THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HI MISS
TAGOVAILOA FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I
UNDERSTAND MISS MOCK ON THE
LINE BUT WANTED TO FOR
QUESTIONS BUT LET ME JUST
CONFIRM YOUR YOUR PRESENCE
THERE ON ON OUR PHONE LINES.
YES I AM CONFIRMING THAT GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO FOR OTHER
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
INDICATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR.
THIS LEGISLATION SB TWENTY
NINE. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO- ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE AND
NOTHING TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE ONLY ASKING IN THIS CASE.
PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION AND IN THIS CASE-
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL SO
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE AS
OR ANYONE WISHES TO TESTIFY.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANYONE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO WITNESSES IN
ROOM. ONE TWELVE. I DON'T SEE
ANY THERE WHO WISH TESTIFY. AND
NOW WE'RE GO TO WE WHO TO TELL
THE TELL. ORVIS MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TO SO INDICATE SO WE CAN. HEAR
FROM THEM. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU DO WISH POSTED BY. ONE
ZERO THIS TIME WHEN THEY'RE.
MODERATED HAVE ANYONE THE LINE
WISHES TO IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE ONE LET'S GIVE
IT A LOT CALL CAN YOU PLEASE
GIVE THE ANSWER ONE TIME AND
GIVE IT TO GIVE IT ONE LAST
CHANCE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THE ROAD. TIMES IT WAS. A.
MONTEREY OR ANYONE SO
INDICATING. SOME OF THEM OKAY
SO WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THE THIS
PORTION OF THE HEARING FOR
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THOSE WHO ARE IN
OPPOSITION. I UNDERSTAND RUTH
WEISS FOR WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA
IS ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITION IS WISE IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING. EFPGA HAVE PROVIDED
OUR LETTER OF OPPOSITION SB
NINE WHICH CONTAINS START AND-
THAT. BELIE THE LOGIC OF EXTENT
THE LEAD OF A EIGHT SIXTY MEN.
THROUGH SB TWENTY NINE. I'M NOT
GOING TO. AND TELL BY RICK. THE
THAT MIGHT HAVE. AND I TRUST
THAT YOU BY. THE SIX OR YOU
WILL BE CASTING VOTE TODAY.
WELL YEAH. JOINT THE LEAD TO.
IN IT IS. TO CAN BEING AND ON
INCOME ACTS TO THE- ALL
ELIGIBLE CAL. SHE VIBE AND-
DEMOCRAT PROCESS CAN TOLERATE.
CURRENT DOES. FOR CLEAR ERROR
IN THE VOTER. AS WHEN RELYING
ON THOSE ROLE TO PROVIDE UNDER.
BY BY MAIL EVERY DAY ON THAT.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA
CAN HAVE NO SAY IN THE- THAT
PERPETRATE. THAT LEAD TO THE-
OF AS THE ONE ARE UP. LETTER
PRINT. MORE I'D LIKE TO ADD
FURTHER. CA IN ON. NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWO. YEAH FEEL THAT
THOUSANDS FOLKS FROM. UPSET
COULD YOU. AND DISSOLUTE VOTERS
WHO HAD. A BALLOT FOR THE YOU
AND DIE. HAVING RECEIVED
BALLOTS DIRECTED TO A GOOD
CLEAN OFTEN LONG DECEASED LOVED
ONES. NO ONE SHOULD BE PUT
THROUGH THE AGONY THAT THEY
FELT AND THE CONTINUED LACK OF
FEDERALLY REQUIRED VOTER ROLL
MAINTENANCE IS THE CULPRIT.
PASSAGE OF SB TWENTY NINE WOULD
PUT THOSE SAME VOTERS AND
OTHERS THROUGH THE SAME TRAUMA
AGAIN. BUT THE MOST TROUBLING
CALLED OF ALL FOR ME WERE THE
ONES FROM NON CITIZENS WORKING
PROPERLY THROUGH THE SYSTEM TO
REACH THEIR GOAL OF US
CITIZENSHIP. KNOWING THE RULES
THEY HAD NEVER REGISTERED TO
VOTE AND THEY RECEIVED A BALLOT
WHICH TERRIFIED THEM AND THEIR
CITIZENS ABOUT THAT. SOME EVEN
SHARED VERY EMOTIONALLY WITH ME
THAT WHEN THEY CALLED THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS IN THE
COUNTY IN A PANIC. THEY WERE
TOLD BY THE PERSON ANSWERING
THE PHONE BUT IF THEY RECEIVE
THE BALLOT THEY WERE ENTITLED
TO USE THAT. AND THEY WERE
ENCOURAGED TO DO SO SOME EVEN
RECEIVED TEXT MESSAGES
REMINDING THEM THAT THEIR
BALLOTS HAD NOT BEEN RECEIVED
AND THE BOAT BEFORE IT WAS TOO
LATE. I OFTEN CRIED ALONG WITH
THESE PEOPLE IN GREAT DISTRESS
OR WHAT THE SITUATION COULD
MEAN FOR THEIR FUTURE. THE VERY
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE WANT TO
ADOPT AND EMBRACE INTO OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY ARE BIG DOGS.
OF FLUORIDE VOTER ROLLS AN
AUTOMATIC REGISTRATION POLICIES
GONE AWRY. AB EIGHT. MAGNIFIED
THE SQUAD FACILITATED GREAT
HARM TO THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS AND DID DAMAGE TO
VOTER CONFIDENCE. WE BEG YOU
TODAY NOT TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
SUCH A DISASTROUS MISTAKE
REJECT SB TWENTY NINE A RETURN
THAT CHOICE THE INDIVIDUAL
VOTER. NO ONE WILL BE HARMED
AND MANY WILL BE SPARED HARM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
IN YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU I MISS WIFE IS WISE FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. I WANT TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE- I DON'T
HAVE ANYONE SCHEDULED IN
OPPOSITION IN ADDITION TO MISS
WISE BUT I WANT TO. OFFER UP
THAT THE- THE COMMITTEES- FOR
ANYONE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
OPPOSITE. LET ME FIRST GO TO
WITNESS HERE AND FOR TWO OH
THREE AS ANYONE WHO. TO TELL.
CENA I'M GONNA GO WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWELVE ISRAEL THERE THAT
WHICH TO TEST. CINEMA A GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES AND ASK THE
OPERATOR TO- ASK THOSE WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION S. B.
TWENTY NINE TO. PLEASE SO
INDICATE SO WE CAN HEAR FROM
THEM. OPERATOR IS THERE. WHERE
I AM AND LITTLEWOODS GUYS- WE
MAY HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO GET
SOME OF THE COMMENTERS.
PREVIOUSLY WHICH TO TESTIFY.
WITH A MOMENT AND WE ARE WHERE
WE ARE WITH THE PEOPLE ARE ON
THE VOTE. SURE IF I MAY I'M TO
OPEN UP LINE EIGHTEEN I NOT
SURE THEY'RE GOING TO BE KOREAN.
I HAVE FOR THAT OKAY NOT A
MOMENT- CONCERN SO IF IN A. AND
YOU CAN PROVIDE YOUR- YES. TONY
TURTURRO I'LL BE HAPPY TO CAL.
TEACHERS AS- IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR NEXT NEXT CALL.
BLIND. FIVE ONE TWENTY FIVE ONE
THOUSAND. THE LINE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME I CAN. GO AHEAD AND
PROVIDE YOUR NAME HERE. I AM SO
SORRY THE CONNECTIONS REALLY
POOR- YEAH MY NAME IS EVA MARIE
DEAL. AND ARE YOU AFFILIATED
WITH ANY ORGANIZATION AND WHAT
POSITION YOU HAVE ON SB TWENTY
NINE. NO I AM NOT DELETED WITH
S. B. WITH ANY ORGANIZATION AND
MY AFFILIATION IS I HAVE NO
AFFILIATION AND MY POSITION ON
IT. IS THAT- WE SHOULD BE
SENDING BALLOTS EVERYBODY
REGARDLESS OF VERIFICATION
WHETHER THEY WANT IT OR NOT
MAKING IT PRONE TO VOTER FRAUD
RIGHT AND THAT I WANT VOTER ID
AND SIGNATURE MATCH. VERY GOOD
WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR
PROVIDING YOUR TESTIMONY ODAY
OPERATOR CAN GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER YOUR- LINE. THIRTY
SEVEN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN ALONG.
PANICUM LINE THIRTY SEVEN. THE
LION. HELLO IT IS A ROBERT
WHITE AND I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWENTY NINE
I BELIEVE THAT IF THE- LATE
WINTER MISTER WHITE WELL CALL
IT HAD JEAN THIS WAY WE JUST
NEEDED TO HAVE YOUR NAME-
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
THAT'S THE PROCESS WE'RE DOING
IN OUR COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
AND SHARING YOUR- AS A- IN
OPPOSITION. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BLIND. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
FORD AND IN SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTY. AT I AM IN TRONG
OPPOSITION TO F. B. TWENTY NINE
I FEEL THAT VERY GOOD MA'AM
THANK YOU FOR FLYING INTERVIEW
LEVINE. THAT THEY JUST REMIND
HIM OF THE CALLERS THAT ARE
WAITING THAT WERE AT THIS POINT
IN THE HEARING WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD TESTIMONY IN FAVOR AND
AGAINST. WE'RE JUST ASKING
PEOPLE TO GET THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL OKAY NO
FURTHER TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT
IN THE HEARING. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE TWENTY SIX
FOR ONE OF THEM. HI MY NAME IS
WAYNE BIGGER OPPOSITION NO
PARTY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
EIGHT. HI THIS IS HI THIS IS C.
VAN PATTEN NO IT'S ONLY ASIAN
NOT SURE WHY DON'T GET BIG
PLANS AND WE HAVE. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING IN. LINE. TWENTY
SEVEN. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME I
CAN'T WE CAN HEAR YOU. YES SIR-
MY NAME IS RAHUL RODRIGUEZ
JUNIOR AND I OPPOSE. SB TWENTY
NINE. I WOULD LIKE TO RODRIGUEZ
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANYTHING ADDITIONALLY EXCEPT
FOR YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
SO TAKE YOUR IN MY AFFILIATION
MAKE AMERICA FIRST LATINOS
RIFIC THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS COLIN IN BRITAIN
I'M WITH CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BOY BAND ELECTION INTEGRITY A
PROJECT CALIFORNIA ALONG NOW
AND AGAIN IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN
OPERATOR NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
ONE TWENTY ONE SOMETHING. HI MY
NAME IS BORN IN THE BACKGROUND
AND RETIRED HEALTHCARE WORKER I
STRONGLY OBJECT TO- THIS
EXTENSION OF THE EMERGENCY
REGULATION VERY MANY PEOPLE
ARE. REACTING AND WE ALL KNOW
HOW TO WEAR NATUFIAN THAT'S
ALSO. ALL INFORMATION ABOUT IN
PERSON. AT. H. LINE OPEN. YES
HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH SCOTT Q.
AND I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION I
WORK AT THE HEADQUARTERS AND
SEVERAL PEOPLE CAME IN WITH
DUPLICATE BALLOTS ARE NOT
HAVING RECEIVED ABOUT IT WAS
VERY UNFAIR AMERICA REGULATORY
MUCH FLYING TWENTY ONE WHICH
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL I
AM GLAD TWENTY ONE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWING US TO GIVE TESTIMONY
BUT- THE EXPECTED MY NAME IS
EUNICE MALLEY. I WOULD SEE
CALIFORNIA- ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT I STRONGLY OPPOSE. IT'S
REASONS. ONE LINERS DON'T.
WINDS OPEN I PAMELA MORAN NOT
AFFILIATED WITH ANYONE I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING AND NECKLINE.
ONE FORTY FOUR ONE SOMETHING.
HELLO OKAY HERE YOU PLEASE HOLD
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS DYLAN MAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CONCERNED
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE
AN ABUNDANCE OF INFORMATION
REGARDING PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER
REGISTERED IN YOUR RECEIVE
BALLOTS AND WE HAVE STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TWENTY NINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING IN
AND OPERATE BEFORE WE GO TO THE
NEXT CALLER LET ME JUST- MAY BE
RECORDED FOR MANY PEOPLE THIS
MIGHT BE THE FIRST TIME THEY'RE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY TO- A
SENATE COMMITTEE BUT WE DO HAVE
A- PROCEDURES IN PLACE WERE WE
ALLOWED FULL TESTIMONY FROM
BOTH SIDES. DURING THE COURSE
OF THE HEARING- IN THIS CASE WE
HAVE- A WITNESS ON BOTH SIDES
AND THEN WE ASK FOR ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO PARTICIPATE TO
JUST GIVE THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
SO IT'S NOT OUT OF DISRESPECT
FOR EITHER SIDE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO BE PARTICIPATE WITH
US IN THIS HEARING PROCESS BUT
THAT'S THE PROCEDURES THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE HERE IN THE
SENATE. OPERATOR IF YOU CAN GO
TO THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
THREE. ONE OF. THIS IS GEORGIA
RIGHT WITH THE SOLANO COUNTY
REPUBLICAN CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
TWENTY NINE. LINED UP BEHIND
THE BILL. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DEANNA POVERTY I'M ORANGE
COUNTY RESIDENTS AND ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
MEMBER I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS CALLER. BLINDFOLDED THE
RIVER LINE IS OPEN. BENESCH
KERN COUNTY RESIDENTS STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU. LINE A LINE THAT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME THAT
I REPRESENT CALL THOUSAND
PARENTS AND WE OPEN CALIFORNIA
AND WE URGE YOU TO REJECT SB
TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING. PINE. FIFTEEN
HELLO I WE COULD HEAR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY MY NAME
IS SUSAN KENNEDY ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT STRONGLY
OPPOSED U. S. B. TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISS KENNEDY THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. ONE TWENTY. ONE
TWENTY ONE BUT- HEY CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I DON'T GREAT HI- MY
NAME IS LINDA BECKER I'M A
RETIRED HEALTH CARE WORKERS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE EXTENSION
OF THE MORE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS. M. YOU KNOW ROBERT
MAXINE AND I THINK THAT WE ALL
KNOW HOW TO THANK YOU NOW THANK
YOU EVERYBODY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY IMPORTANT WE WORK ON
VETERANS DAY. PARADE BEFORE WE
GO TO THE NEXT. PERSON HOW MANY
OTHER PEOPLE ARE IN QUEUE
PLEASE. WE HAVE A LOT VERY GOOD
PLEASE GO TO THE CALLER. PINE
FIFTY. YES MY NAME IS THE LAST
NAME IS AND I'M A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY RESIDENT NIGHT STRONGLY
OPPOSE- S. B. TWENTY NINE I DO
NOT THINK WE NEED TO HAVE MORE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ABOUT IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT ONE TWENTY NINE LINES OPEN.
MY NAME IS ROBIN BATES STAN I'M
WITH WE THE PEOPLE RISING I'D
STRONGLY OPPOSE S. B. TWENTY
NINE WE NEED VOTER ID THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN LINE.
NINE FORTY NINE ONE. HI THIS IS
RYAN TOWARD AN ORANGE COUNTY
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HELP. THE WIND RESPECT.
FRANKLIN BUILDING. SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY RESIDENTS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE IT AND THINK WE NEED
VOTER ID BUILDING PERSONAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MR WE HAVE NO. TIME TO
COMMENT VERY GOOD OPERATOR
LET'S DO A LAST AND FINAL CALL
FOR ANYONE WISH TO TESTIFY- ON
ON THIS LEGISLATION COULD YOU
ASK ONE LAST TIME. THE NEW WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY AT THIS TIME.
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE HAVE
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE COMING UP THIS TIME.
OPERATOR THAT'S THAT THAT'S IT
THERE'S NO FURTHER. FOLKS ON
THE LINE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
BROUGHT PEOPLE TO OPERATE NOW.
I'M NOT. BLIND THIRTY SEVEN. BY
THE SEVEN ALONG ABOUT. THE LINE
THIRTY ONE LINE THIRTY ONE
SOMETHING. YES THANK YOU THIS
IS CAROLINE FEATHER LONG TIME
ELECTION WORKER AN OBSERVER AND
REPRESENTING ELECTION INTEGRITY
CALIFORNIA I AM STRONGLY
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE Q. SB TWENTY
NINE THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR ANY FURTHER CALLERS.
YES LINE FORTY THE LINE ITSELF
AND- I ALREADY- WAITIN ARE YOU
ALLOWING ANY FURTHER TESTS. NO
SORRY ABOUT THAT BUT JUST JUST
ONE TIME SO THANK YOU AGAIN AND
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE FIFTY TWO- THIS IS MARCIA
HAWKINS FROM I'M A REGISTERED
VOTER 
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TWENTY NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE FIFTY
ONE. CONSTRUCT ONE YOUNG
LIFTING MY NATIONAL AND WE ARE
IN PART ACT THE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. LINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM SENDING
SAN DIEGO NO PART OF IT- MOSTLY
ASIAN STRONGLY OPPOSED. LINE
TWENTY FOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BETTY
ROBINSON I'M FROM ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A MEMBER OF
CONCERNED CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO WE THE PEOPLE
RISING AND I AM ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO S. B. TWENTY NINE WE
GET THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE FIFTY FIVE ROOM IS
OPEN. HI I AM MARIANNE SANTOS
FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY I AM
OPPOSED TO S. B. TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN LINE
WITH A- LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CANCEL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M DONNA MAGUIRE I
LIVE IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN A POLL WATCHER
I'VE BEEN A CREEK DR AND I ALSO
WORKED ON SETTING THE VOTER
LIST THROUGHOUT ORANGE COUNTY
I'M ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO SB
TWENTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
EXPELLED THERE'S NO GOING
FURTHER INTO THE MIX I'M NOT.
VERY GOOD OPERATOR THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR HELP TODAY- THANK
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO PROVIDED
TESTIMONY IN PERSON OR- OVER
THE PHONE WHEN DRIVING A MOVE
TO THE NEXT PHASE OF OUR
HEARING GOING TO INVITE MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMITTEE. WHO HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO- OFFER
THEM UP NOW I SAW CENTER
HERTZBERG AND SENATOR NELSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THOSE WHO
TOOK THE TIME TO TESTIFIED
TODAY BEFORE THE SENATE HEARING.
MORE MAKE SOME COMMENTS BECAUSE
THIS IS BEEN AN ISSUE I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH IN. FOR MANY
DECADES AND HARM DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ELECTIONS AND
VOTING. THE PROCESS INCLUSION
AND FIGURING OUT WAYS AS WE
LEARN TO NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
ALL HOST OF WAYS TO MAKE VOTING
WORK WE HAVE GRAPPLED WITH THIS
ISSUE SINCE THE CONSTITUTION
WAS ADOPTED WHEN ONLY
PROTESTANT WHITE MEN. WHO OWNED
LAND COULD VOTE AND WE HAVE
SINCE ENGAGED IN A VERY
DETAILED AND DIFFICULT
DISCUSSION OF WHAT VOTING MEANS
AND HOW WE DEAL WITH IT- IN
CALIFORNIA UNTIL NINETEEN
THIRTEEN MOST OF THE STATE
BUDGET BEFORE WE ACTUALLY HAD A
FORMALIZED STATE BUDGET WAS
FUNDED BY THE POLL TAX WHAT
THAT MEANS. THE MEN ONLY PEOPLE
THAT HAD MONEY WHO COULD AFFORD
TO VOTE ACTUALLY PARTICIPATED
IN TERMS OF WHAT KIND OF
REPRESENTATION WE REALLY HAD IN
CALIFORNIA- WE'VE HAD IS WITH
AS MANY NO LITERACY TESTS THAT
WERE EXCLUSIONARY AS DEVOTED TO
THE IDEA OF VOTING IS A BALANCE
IN THE ULTIMATE BALANCE SHOULD
BE INFORMED BY. INSURING THAT
YOU HAVE THE GREATEST LEVEL OF
PARTICIPATION BY THE GREATEST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE THE AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE TESTIFIED THAT WE
SEE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
TURNOUT SINCE EISENHOWER WAS
PRESIDENT NOTHING LESS THAN
EXTRAORDINARY. TODAY WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOMEBODY MIGHT GET A
BALLOT FOR SOMEBODY WAS
DECEASED THAT CAN CHECK THOSE
THINGS OUT I INTRODUCED THIS
VERY BILL IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN WHEN I CAME BACK TO THE
SENATE BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT AT THE TIME A NUMBER
OF REGISTRAR'S THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA DID NOT SUPPORTED
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T FEEL
TECHNOLOGICALLY. THAT THEY WERE
READY TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
THIS KIND OF. ADDITIONAL
INCREASE IN WORK AND THEY
CLEARLY HAVE DONE SO NOW AND
CLEARLY WE'VE SEEN AS A RESULT
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
HANDLING OF THE SELECTION
THEY'VE DONE SO PRETTY
BRILLIANTLY AND THAT THEY
REALLY HE HAS NOT BEEN ANY. OF
WIDESPREAD FRAUD AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOME OF THE BE
RESPECTFUL OF SOME OF THOSE WHO
TESTIFIED WHICH I CERTAINLY AM.
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN THE
BALLOT. THAT SO IF SOMEBODY
RECENTLY DECEASED THE BALANCE
OF THAT IS WHAT'S THE IMPACT ON
SOCIETY FOR PEOPLE THAT DON'T
GET BALLOTS. FOR PEOPLE THAT-
YOU KNOW I DID LEGISLATION SOME
YEARS AGO DEALING WITH- TRYING
TO MOVE AWAY FROM THE THIRTY
DAY REGISTRATIONS SOMEBODY WHO
WAS A RENTER WHO AND IT MOVED
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY GET SOME-
THEY SEE SOME ADVERTISING ON TV
FOR A CANDIDATE BUT THEY
REALIZE THEY'RE BARRED. FROM
PARTICIPATING BECAUSE OF THE
THIRTY DAYS WE WERE ABLE TO GET
GOVERNOR DAVIS AT THE TIME TO
MAKE IT UP. FIFTEEN DAYS AND
NOW UNDER LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES
WE HAVE SAME DAY REGISTRATION
ALL OF WHICH TECHNOLOGY ALLOWS
US. TO VALIDATE. AND SO.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE SACRED IS
WERE DEBATING THESE ISSUES NOW
CROSS THIS COUNTRY THEN THE
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE. AND
TECHNOLOGY HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
ARM IMPROVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
SURE IN THAT BALANCE THAT THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF HUMAN BEINGS
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR NOT
SYSTEMICALLY BARRED FROM THE
SYSTEM WHICH HAS HAPPENED TO US
SO MUCH OF OUR HISTORY. IN THE
UNITED STATES AND CALIFORNIA SO
I MAKE THESTATEMENT AND
APOLOGIZE W. QUESTION I JUST
THINK I WANT TO PUT THIS ON THE
RECORD AND SOME MORE HISTORICAL
CONTEXT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW WHEN
pI WAS. IN GOVERNMENT WHEN. WHEN
WE HAD THE- ISSUE IN FLORIDA
WITHOUT GORE TO FIND OUT THAT
53% OF THE MACHINE VOTING
MACHINES THAT WE HAD. IN
CALIFORNIA. 53% OF THOSE
MACHINES HAD HANGING CHADS
WHICH WERE IN SO WE DID A BOND
MEASURE TO GET ELIMINATE THOSE
MACHINES TO AVOID ANY QUESTION
AGAIN. ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE ELECTIONS. SO THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE TO A NUMBER OF
THE VARIOUS ADVOCACY GROUPS
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH FOR
MANY MANY YEARS. CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT IT AND WOULD CERTAINLY
LIKE. TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE IF THAT
WOULD BE OKAY WITH YOU- TERM-
BURKE- I CERTAINLY AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS AND I JUST WANTED
TO GIVE SOME GREATER HISTORICAL
CONTEXT. AS WE DEBATE THIS
CRITICAL CRITICAL ISSUE TO
ENSURE THAT THE GREATEST NUMBER
OF PEOPLE. ARE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND THAT WE HAVE
THE SAFEGUARDS NOW TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS SO I CERTAINLY WOULD
SUPPORT YOUR MESURE AND THANK
YOU FOR INDULGING ME ON THAT
TIME- AND ALLOWING TO EXPRESS
MY THINKING ON THIS. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG CENTER NIELSEN.
YES THURMOND. I AM SPEAKING TO
SEPARATE TO LODGE OBJECTIONS.
TO THE WAY SENATE IS CON
CONDUCTING ITS BUSINESS THESE
DAYS. I WANTED FORMALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE EVEN AND COMMITTEES
NOW FOR YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
ALLOWING A PRESENTER. AND THEN
INDIVIDUALS SOMETIMES A THREE
WHICH VARIEDFROM TIME TO TIME
COMMITTEE BY COMMITTEE BUT
THREE PEOPLE TO MORE
EXPANSIVELY TESTIFY AND
EVERYBODY ELSE GETS TO COME UP
AND SAY THEIR NAMES AND WIFE. I
DO NOT CONSIDER THAT PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN THIS GOT NO
REFERENCE TO THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL BECAUSE I HAVE THE HIGHEST
RESPECT. FOR THIS AUTHOR. IT'S
A GENERAL OBSERVATION. BAG
RELATED INCREDIBLY FOR ME LAST
MONDAY WHEN THE SENATE CHANGED
ITS RULES. OF SENATORS
REPRESENTING ONE MILLION PEOPLE
ARE NOW STARTING. FROM
PRESENTING THEIR OPINIONS IN
THE STATE SENATE. WITH THAT
DEGREE JUST AFTER THAT THE HAS
BEEN TAKEN HERE IN THE SENATE
I'M NOW GOING TO BE OBJECTING
EVEN IN OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
TWO STIFLING THE PUBLIC INPUT.
HOW FRUSTRATING IT'S GOT TO BE
FOR THE AVERAGE CITIZEN WANTS
TO HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD IN
GOVERNMENT. AND THEY GET TO SAY
I'M JONES AND I LIKE OR DISLIKE.
THAT'S THE EXTENT OF THE
COMMUNICATION THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDED. IN THE OPEN SEVEN.
AND FOR MEMBERS REPRESENTING
ONE MILLION PEOPLE TO HAVE
THEIR VOICES STIFLED BY SILLY
RULES LIKE THE ONES WE PASSED
MONDAY. I'M PRETTY IRRITATED
ABOUT THIS GERMAN AND THAT'S
WHY I FORMALLY WANT MINE OCT
OPPOSITION AND OBJECTION.
EVENED TO THE PROCEDURE HERE
TODAY. AND I CERTAINLY CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR. NEWMAN
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY- THE FIRST WITNESS WAS
ADMINISTERED THEY'LL TAKE A
LOWER FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY
TREASURE'S OFFICE I WANT TO
COMMEND. A MISTAKE LOW AND ALL
HER STAFF AND IN FACT THE
STATUS OF ALL THE REGISTRATION
MY DISTRICT WHICH THREE COUNTY
SAN MARINO LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AS WELL. TO SOME OF THE POINTS
OF THE OBSERVED TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE
SIGNATURE MATCHING. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF OTHER VERY THOROUGH
CHECKS- IN THIS ELECTION WAS BY
ALL INDICATIONS THE FAIREST AND
MOST ACCURATE ELECTION IN SOME
TIME IT CAME WITH THE ADDED
BONUS OF PROVIDING ACCESS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
PARTICIPATE. WE SHOULD OF
COURSE CONTINUE TO IMPROVE AND
PROTECT THE ELECTIONS PROCESS I
THINK WE'RE DOING THAT
PROGRESSIVELY THAT THE GOALS OF
THIS BILL DO NOT IMPINGE UPON
THAT IN FACT THAT THEY GIVE US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT
WHILE OFFERING. AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN A VERY
CHALLENGING TIME THIS PANDEMIC
WILL BE WITH US FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT- THAT OUR
ELECTION PROCESSES DO NOT
SUFFER CHAU THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR- AND I WOULD ALSO BE
HONORED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN CENTER LEYVA
THANK YOU MISTERCHAIR GOOD
MORNING- I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AS WELL TODAY AND YOU
KNOW I THINK TAT WE SHOULD
ALWAYS STRIVE TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR TO VOTE ISN'T THAT WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION WANTS HIS PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO VOTE AND LET
THEIR VOICE BE HEARD. AND WHAT
BETTER WAY TO LET YOUR VOICE BE
HEARD THAT HAVING ACCESS TO
VOTING WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ISN'T VOTER FRAUD WE
KNOW THAT THAT DID NOT HAPPEN-
IN TE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MAYBE ONE OR TWO BUT CERTAINLY
NOT WIDESPREAD VOTER FRAUD. I
HAPPEN uTHINK
PROCEDURE ALLOWS MORE PEOPLE TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AS A
GOOD SENATOR FROM TO HEYMAN
NOTED PEOPLE USED TO HAVE TO
COME UP TO SACRAMENTO STAND IN
A LINE OVER HERE AND JUST SAY.
THEIR NAME AND WHETHER THEY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE NOW HE CAN
CALL IN TO DO IT FROM COMFORT
OF THEIR OWN. AND I HOPE THAT
WE ONTINUE DO THAT EVEN ONCE A
PANDEMIC IS OVER. SO I'M HAPPY
TO BE HERE AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA- AT THE
MEDIA OFFER A FEW A FEW
OBSERVATIONS FIRST- IN REGARD
TO OUR PROCESS AND PROCEDURES.
I WOULD TO ECHO THE- THE WISDOM
FROM A SET OF THE SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES THAT. WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY NOT ALLOWED PEOPLE
TO- TESTIFIED VIA PHONE LINES
AND- I THINK IT'S BEEN AN
EXTRAORDINARY- EXTENSION OF OUR
DESIRE TO HAVE INPUT FROM OUR
CITIZENRY THAT WE'VE NOW- IN
THIS PANDEMIC CIRCUMSTANCE-
PROVIDED FOR THAT AND- ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT. TESTIFIED VIA
PHONE TODAY I CERTAINLY DIDN'T
HAVE THE COST AND INCONVENIENCE
OF ALL THE TRAVEL SO THAT WE
pCOURSE OF OUR DELIBERATIONS SO-
IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT I
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THE SENATE
IS SAID TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING
IT CAN TO- RES. IMPORT AND
TESTIMONY IN OUR IN OUR WORK.
BUT LET ME I GO TO THE BILL
THAT AT HAND I WANT TO- ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM THE
SENATOR FROM LA THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IN REGARD TO
THE HISTORY OF EFFORTS TO
EXPAND VOTING. OPPORTUNITIES
AYE AYE YOU MAY NOT RECALL
SENATOR HERTZBERG IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN WHEN I AS
WORKING FOR THE GOVERNOR- THAT
WE MADE AN EFFORT IN OUR
LEGISLATION- IN OUR FIRST YEAR
TO TRY TO- IN A SPECIAL
ELECTION THAT WAS ANTICIPATED.
IN THAT YEAR TO HAVE AS A
COMPONENT OF IT AND ALL MAIL
ELECTION AND WE WENT TO AND DO
A CONSIDERABLE- RESEARCH IN
TERMS OF THOSE PROGRAMS
HAPPENING AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND WHAT HAS BEEN WORKING WHAT
HAD BEEN NOT- SO I CERTAINLY
THINK WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A PROCESS
THAT WORKS. AND I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- IN COMMENDING AND
CONGRATULATING THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND OUR REGISTRARS FROM
AROUND THE STATE WHO DID SUCH A
MARVELOUS JOB IN THIS ELECTION
SEASON I TO GET THE BALLOTS OUT
TO SO MANY AND HAVE THIS GREAT
LEVEL OF PARTICIPATION IT
REALLY IS A- A GREAT HALLMARK
OF THEIR SERVICE. AND I KNOW
THAT THE SENATE. YOUR EFFORTS
ARE TO CONTINUE THAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN THIS. YEAR THAT
WE'RE IN NOW TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A PLACE THAT
SAME A PROCESS THAT IS A
HEALTHY ONE FOR INCLUDING AN
INCREASING- TURNED OUT I THINK
THAT. THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
TO DO THAT AT THIS YEAR AS WE-
AGAIN TRY TO LEARN FROM THE
PROCESS SEE WERE WE- CAN DO IT
BETTER. I DO NOTE THAT THE THAT
THERE WAS SOME TESTIMONY ABOUT
SOME ISSUES THERE ARE ALWAYS
ISSUES- BUT NONE OF IT. NONE OF
THEM- WITH ANY AT THAT SIZE OR
ANY- IMPACT ON ANY OF THE RACES
IN THE STATE WE CAN ALWAYS LOOK
FOR WAYS TO DO BETTER. I WOULD
INVITE THIS MOCK REPRESENTING
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
TO. TAKE THOSE CONCERNS TO
HEART AND I WOULD LOOK FORWARD
TO AN OPPORTUNITY. TO VISIT
WITH THAT THAT OFFICE- TO WHAT
TO REVIEW THOSE ISSUES SO THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO LOOK OR
WAYS. TO DO IT BETTER I WANNA
INVITE THE AUTHOR CENTER I'M
BURKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS BEFORE WE- WE WELCOME
IN THE OCEAN. WELL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. LET ME ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES VERY
ELOQUENTLY STATED IN TERMS OF
THE- A- CENTER. OLD ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO EITHER THE EXPANSION
OF THE CONTRACTION. OF
FRANCHISE THIS BILL CLEARLY.
STANDS ON THE SIDE OF
INCREASING FRANCHISE TO THOSE
WHO ARE. ELIGIBLE TO VOTE WHAT
WITH ONE CORRECTION- I KNOW MY-
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES
WOULD WOULD NOT BE- WANT TO BE
AN ERROR ON THE RECORD AS- IT
WAS PRESIDENT TRUMAN. ACTUALLY
WAS THE LAST TIME THAT WE HAD
THIS KIND OF. ROBUST TURNOUT
CALIFORNIA A COUPLE OF OTHER
THINGS AND TO THOSE WHO ARE.
CONCERNED ABOUT IRREGULARITIES.
CERTAINLY ANY REPORT OF
IRREGULARITY SHOULD BE CONVEYED
TO THE LOCAL POLICE LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TRANSECTED
STATE AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THEM TO DO SO THAT THERE IS A-
ROBUST. BODY OF INFORMATION
THAT CAN BE INVESTIGATED IT'S
BEEN DONE IN THE PAST WE'VE NOT
FOUND WIDESPREAD FRAUD AND I
WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE THEM. TO-
CONTACT THE FOR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ACTUALLY FLIP SEEDS
AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO MAIL
VOTING BECAUSE ONCE THEY'RE
WHERE THOSE REGULARS MY GUESS
IS THE ONE A STEP DOWN AND HAVE
A SPECIAL ELECTION SO THAT THEY
COULD. BE ELECTED UNDER OTHER
CONDITIONS- HAVING SAID THAT- I
URGE A NO VOTE. EIGHTY CENTER
I'M BURKE IS THERE A MOTION
FROM THE COMMITTEE CENTER
HERTZBERG HAS MOVED THE BILL DO
PASS AS AMENDED WE REFERRED TO
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- AND WITH THAT IF THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
OKAY MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RECRUIT REFER TO
FIND AT PERFORATIONS COMMITTEE.
FLAVOR HI LEVER HI NIELSEN NO.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG ARGUED
BURKE FIVE LEYVA AYE LEYVA FIVE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI THE
BILL- IS OUT FOUR TO ONE
GRADUATION CENTER I'M REFLECTS
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE-
AND WITH THAT I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER BUSINESS- PENDING BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE- THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL MEMBERS. THANK YOU THE